a spencer ackerman here with danger room
big challenge for the army in Iraq and
Afghanistan how do you protect against
incoming RPG rounds like this the
standard answer the Army's offer is to
add more armor to its vehicle's problem
with that is more mass means a much
slower vehicle and the rounds can still
penetrate so sub the guys who make all
those Swedish cars have a different
answer and they call it the l.e.d.s
or the laser electronic defense system
that takes around about this size
ammunition that station on top of an
army vehicle and after finding an
incoming RPG round with a late with a
radar sensor it shoots it out actually
at the round explodes over the incoming
RPG missile or what have you
takes out the round in what they say is
as little as a hundred and twenty
milliseconds after detection whether
this works or not who knows it's still
in testing and Saab thinks that by 2013
it can possibly sell the army on this
system